- all right Roman and Jessie right but
everybody calls me flame flame and this
is my Harley Quinn wait where you guys
from
oh she's from Thousand Oaks and for
Macquarie Hills so kind of West Valley
of Los Angeles
um interacademy tell me buddy childhood
you get both both your parents wrong the
childhood would have to start with I had
my mother and my grandfather and my
grandmother my father was not in the
picture because my mom she was obviously
partying and doing drugs and put my dad
in jail for what is it called
child support purposes and to gain
custody me so I grew up in a nice big
mansion house my mom's actress my
grandfather's a capital of interest and
until I was 13 and my mom dated a man
who was involved in some things and
sadly my mom was murdered but they
concluded as a suicide in 2011 from
there I started I started rebelling
tattooing my face thinking it was cool
you're going to jail although he tells a
teen
turn 18 met a girl she was involved with
robbing houses so she robbed a bunch of
houses I took the charges cuz she was um
gonna have my kid and they're killing my
kid I did five years in prison just got
out I met my beautiful life I'm not
gonna say that didn't intentionally I
would say that that crystal
methamphetamine killed our child because
that's what ultimately was the major
problem but that's irrelevant at this
room we're focused on early now we're
gonna have a beautiful beautiful
beautiful boy or girl
so you're pregnant just so that back to
your child that you lost someone was
giving you crystal meth um just out of
respect I like to like talk about that
apart this dumb pattern Oh No
I just know that it's not that
everything is supposed to happen for the
reason that it happens you know and you
know it wasn't meant to happen it wasn't
like giving Chrystal's present that was
pregnant was injecting crystal and yeah
it's very unfortunate but it's a build
me into the man I am today very strong
so when did when the drug start you um
Tina started smoking weed in jail and it
may look like from body language and
whatnot and that anybody's in my head
but that I have a jug probably it's just
the things that I've been buying through
recently in the past four weeks with
this pandemic and being out of jail and
seeing the world for what it truly is
it's just the initial shock and then
I'll not handle it I have a lot of like
anxiety so I might my body language
looks the way it does
my stutters when I talk away do cuz that
I don't really not express myself except
through my music I'm actually a company
owner um I would company entertainment
company called royal enlighten bloodline
entertainment and what I focus on is in
enlight me individuals that burn the
dark and not so much bragging or saying
I'm better than or just showing them
through expression and making them feel
good that there's something more to life
thing and with people think then you
start thinking that's when everything
[ __ ] everything failed but if you
weren't thinking you were just relaxing
in and being the being that we
supposed to be then we'd be freaky
you're chopping you your mom was an
actress my mom she was the actress model
of who put the labels on occupation um
more so she was a star she was a figure
a Hollywood figure somebody famous
oh she was in Lost Boys she wasn't queen
of the dance she dated Robert Downey jr.
oh she was wasn't she the Prince weekend
he had his club in Hollywood
joey is Groening Gambino crime family
wanted big producer friends young
records and and whatnot and it's just
because all these take higher up you
meet people doesn't make bigger and so
it's just it's something that exciting
he's just entertainment and and instead
of watching movies of the kid I was
behind it seems helping like the scripts
to Meryton and directing me money and
more elite status you haven't seen that
you know so yes well Sue's actress my
auntie she's a photographer as yourself
a beautiful beautiful woman was
psychotic anything right now I have no I
I have no idea why nor do I want a
question it I just got away from your oh
no no no I have god damn you and you
ingest the Rose Garden
so Jesse what's your star you don't wear
any thousand Oh
yeah I kind of been through a lot lately
and I think I'll start from each other I
think open up a little bit it's hard for
her to express up to I usually speak for
for the frequency vibrations are easy
but this is your time to like express
yourself in paint you know quite a few
have to learn just talk to me very hard
and this is a big deal to open up for me
to talk to start to meeting you later
charlie
goodbye hey no privilege dragons um I
grew up in Ventura County blessed to
been raised there and I know it um I was
always so quick to tell everybody who's
from where I'm from that they are
blessed and that uh hard come on what
did she do
my mom is a hairdresser and has been for
45 years
yeah 45 years and that's why you've got
the inspiration so yeah see the
cosmetology and know I've been doing
here since I was 13
drugs since I was like I know where it
all started so um I mean the Herricks
brought out the creativity so it was
more like an escape away from the drugs
because I made the drugs more important
I guess it's just recreation
um that was their pain behind knowing
why you're doing it looks like is there
a reason that you had to escape me
physically if you're having a great nice
childhood there was no easy to even
escape but it no remorse deeper think
I'm not really
I respect that well I would live see her
but then on the sex do you think that as
my should even know but you know I know
it's hard to do but you have to love
like did drugs like are just a like
occupation you can't and the other
person can't look at you say oh you do
judge it has relevance like oh you drink
soda which I'm never nice to know you
there's more to you than just all my
heroin that I miss at it mind you she
just got sober cold turkey for weeks for
our relationship and our baby cold
turkey is from heroin 15 years she was
slamming for 15 years and just stop for
me there excuse me itself I mean it's
the most emotional and then having to
deal with my family on top of all of
that and the betrayal I mean I'm
heartbroken and cities and things were
expressed cuz I went to jail over in our
relationship and I found out that I was
in jail but I I forgive because we were
so solid in our relationship and you
know I I did it was but it was both
equally apart and I take full
responsibility for my part but that's
something that's the biggest thing I've
ever had to do in my life we step up
free effort I forgive you because I've
been forgiven so many times and I got on
my hands and knees today for two hours
and screamed to this guy saying if
there's any higher power I give up all
negative all evil all anything voodoo
hex is anything on me cast it away from
me and I allow all positivity don't find
out our relationship and then here
your friend comes down the street on a
bike and I have I have the plan for you
I have a plan for you and I met you
that's why you're very really noise I
really hate to say it like them you're
not considered like transit or homeless
and we're sovereign and free but that we
have that we have a place to go her
parents house the only reason I can go
to our parents house yeah well let's be
honest or no person or her father and I
we didn't really get along only because
I like loud music I'm a rapper and he's
older and likes turning down the music
and he kind of got at me other side
where's my bathing hey who do you think
you just walk all over me I'm a little
[ __ ] and when I hear that word I
instantly reacted and even though that's
her father we're men at the end of the
day and and then punching him in his
face so even he forgave me I forgave him
and I'm not allowed to go over there and
we don't need to rely on anybody else
for it you know I'm a freelancer I have
ways to make money I'm also a webmaster
Computers is my specialty music is my
specialty operating operating anything
on a computer such as businesses virtual
network programming fishing smile and
anything anything you make photo editing
so Jessie are you looking forward to
this baby was your first yeah did you
know it's a boy or girl myself firstly
self-employed I always started her
business
oh well she's actually on the plate I
I make beats freelance I met websites I
develop my photo edit DJ right now I
don't have the foundation I have had the
foundations you even set up anything I
have two phones if I were to have three
four days episode I'll have my own spot
at the right after that something like
evening just to be off to see four days
think clearly we've been walking in
Tucson I had to leave my auntie's house
and go homeless in the state got myself
all guards all the way back back you're
not explicit those tickets are and
having nothing but just my wordplay and
you know what God got is her honesty
truly it was this one guy here because
if you're manipulative each other
manipulator for angle and people notice
that this letter instantly and I'm
grateful that that we're on this path
that were on and honesty in choosing
integrity and I was getting a little bit
more deeper than I expected so Roman do
you say your mom your mom is dead or
she's alive yet no please yeah we'll
stop right that's the template all right
yeah that's personal for you yeah
I'm sorry and so where do you see if you
think you'll settle down in Los Angeles
or where you go well hopefully after
today like I'm unwilling I'm wanting to
collaborate with whatever I don't know
specifically what it is that you
understand and I think if you do
photography interviewing I don't know
what it's for the content oh but I'll
know do I carry because you you open
your your studio to it I would just like
to settle down we've already said oh
don't worry we need soon that's right
here so everyone needs settle down that
so now we're not using judge I smoke I
smoke weed and um I do things I send a
bathroom it's my business you know every
once awhile to get to do my music and
take away the stress from the thing get
it do it - oh yeah act like I have it
all figured out but I don't I have it
all figured out what I know like I don't
know everything I'll be down here and
there I'm just tired I'm tired tired of
be nice
excited listed on my feet
no black don't even know whether in gang
the gangs are way worse they're good
fair that my girlfriend pregnant walking
that [ __ ] whatever human trafficking you
know scary not only for me but for the
joke right
oh these guys are gonna try to piss me
out the one guy he said you guys can
stay in our motel room and when I got
into the motel room we said well what do
you need
I said I don't need any things like okay
well you guys can use that bit and I was
okay I'll say I'm gonna get some answers
that you're not leaving easy well if
you'll even gotta leave your [ __ ] here
and then what like and mind you I can't
do anything
huge got three of his homeboys I'm in a
different state and tons of people out
there you know ask is all I could do is
make sarcastic jokes at her and she's
thinking I'm playing around smoke a
cigarette
Oh quick it's escape and my I haven't
even in let's take a deep breath and
even relax just hours thank you so much
for talking with you guys thank you good
luck with your baby and you guys go from
somewhat simpie
you